dans les rues de saint quentin en
yvelines les passants foule
quotidiennement s'étale publicitaires ou
politique un moyen de communication
visible et peu coûteux né il y a
quelques années que n'approuvent pas
tous les citoyens différents collectif
antipub ont lancé ce mardi une opération
nettoyage contre ces tags illégaux et ce
n'était pas gagné un logis transcender
décline tag donc normalement qui ont été
aspergés à haute pression avec de la
craie
s'était promis que sa partie avec les
premiers intempéries on voit bien que là
c'est pas le cas du tout effectivement
l'eau ne suffit pas alors on frotte la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines indique avoir
contacté l'entreprise rono à propos des
tags cette dernière a précisé que les
premières pluies suffirait à les faire
disparaître
le mouvement initié par des étudiants
est soutenu par l'université de saint
quentin en yvelines qui a prêté le
matériel de nettoyage mais pour ces
militants l'initiative devrait venir des
collectivités
je sais aussi qu apparaît par exemple
ils font payer aux bénéficiaires donc
des publicités les factures justement et
font payer une amende tout d'abord et en
plus de ça et leur font payer le coût du
nettoyage les collectifs ont envoyé
aujourd'hui un courrier aux
municipalités de l'agglomération pour
les inciter à agir